Today we discuss communism, Marxism.
We will discuss uh what it is,
where did it come from and why did it
succeed. Now the 20th century um had the
cold war and so that was an ideological
struggle between capitalism and
communism. And for the longest time we
believe that capitalism
and communism
were polar opposites,
a dialectic, okay, a black and white.
But if that is the case, then how do we
explain
China?
Because for the longest time, China was
a communist country and then in 1980s it
started to reform and now China is very
much a capitalist country. In fact, if
you think about it, this transition has
been seamless. There hasn't been much
conflict because of this transition. And
this is not true historically where um
transitions have been very violent.
Okay? Okay. So, think of the transition
from um feudalism to capitalism. Okay.
That was a very violent process. Think
of the process from Catholic Europe into
Protestant Europe. That was also a very
violent process. But in China, communism
transitioned into capitalism pretty
easily, pretty quickly and extremely
successfully. Okay? And in fact you
could say that today China is very much
a capitalist country with some communist
elements but it's very much
capitalistic. So the question then is if
these two ideologies capitalism
communism are such polar opposites if
it's a dialectic then how this happened
in China and what I want to show you
today is that actually this is a false
dialectic okay meaning that communism
and capitalism are actually more similar
than they are different in fact what I
will show you is that [snorts]
in many ways communism is a creation of
capitalism as a weapon to destroy
capitalism capitalism's major enemies.
Okay, so communism is not really the
enemy of capitalism. The real enemies of
capitalism are different ideologies.
Okay, so these ideologies include
monarchy.
The idea of monarchy is that rather than
power in the hands of a capitalist,
power is in the hand of the king. Okay?
And what a king often does is
redistribute
capital in a way that is more fair. So
for example, when a king first comes
into power, what a king often does is
cancel all debts and redistribute the
land. And that's why he's so popular.
Okay? So capitalists are afraid of
kings. They don't want kings because a
king will often redistribute property.
Another great enemy of capitalism is
religion or theocracy.
Okay. The idea here is that all
religions teach you that money is evil.
Right?
God doesn't want you to make money. God
wants you to be kind to others, to love
your children,
to be a nice person. Okay?
So that's why in Catholic Europe, they
were so poor because people were more
focused on redemption and salvation than
they were on making money. Okay? So
theocracy is also a major enemy of
capitalism. Then you also have
nationalism.
[snorts]
Nationalism is the idea of loyalty to
your people, loyalty to your nation. For
capitalism, that's a problem. Okay?
Because capitalism wants to be loyal to
capital and it wants capital to flow
through across borders. So I see an
investment opportunity in China. I want
to take my money from America and put it
into China. I don't want to worry about
oh China's my enemy. China is not my
people. Okay. So nationalism is also a
major problem.
And then you also have another problem
okay called democracy.
So believe it or not capitalists hate
democracy.
Why do they hate democracy? Because if
you think about it, if people had power,
the workers had power, they would all
get together and vote to redistribute
wealth, right? To make the rich pay more
taxes. We call this socialism.
Okay? So, you think about it, the enemy
of capitalism is not communism. It's
these four other things. If you you
actually think about it. Okay?
Communism
is is working with capitalism to destroy
all four of these things, right? So
let's look at this [snorts] monarchy.
Okay, communism does not allow for
monarchs to arise. It allows for a party
to arise, right? What is a party? Party
is an oligarchy.
All right, which is a capitalist system.
Now theocracy what does Mark say? Mark
says is that religion is the opiate of
the people. Religion is the great evil
of the world. Religion creates false
consciousness. Therefore we must destroy
all religion. Right? And if religion is
destroyed what is left? The only thing
that is left is money.
Okay. Now nationalism national communism
is international.
Right? Workers of the world unite. So
nationalism is also bad.
We want to unite as a world. All workers
unite. The class consciousness is more
important than national identity. Right?
Now democracy. No, no, no. This is bad
too. Right? Because workers cannot
um defend their rights. Workers have
false consciousness. Workers have been
brainwashed by the capitalists in
school, in the media, by the internet,
by Hollywood. Okay? Therefore, a
vanguard, the party must lead the people
into socialism.
All right?
So this is really convenient how
capitalist and communism have similar
enemies and communism helps destroy all
four enemies in a way that capitalism
cannot.
Right?
So you could also you could also make
the argument that maybe
communism was a weapon
or a virus
[clears throat]
created by capitalism in order to
conquer the world in order to destroy
the world so that capitalism can spread
throughout the world.
And China is an example of this, right?
Think of think about the cultural
revolution that destroyed religion, that
destroyed tradition, that destroy
cultural identity. And what happened
after the cultural revolution?
China became capitalist and it became
hyper capitalistic. China had the
fastest growth rate, economic growth
rate in the world. How did that happen?
Okay. So, I'm not saying this is true.
I'm saying like this something for us to
think about. All right. All right.
So let us now think about this and again
um this is all just speculation on my
part okay I don't really know I'm saying
like you know why is this happening why
is this the correlation
right all right so an example is Kar
Marx
and Kar marks of course is the founder
of communism
um and the history of K Marx is like
really really strange
So for example
um he is a German citizen but he spent
all his time in Britain. He was exiled
from Germany because they advocated for
world revolution. So he went to Britain.
But Britain is also a capitalistic
country. So why is it that he's allowed
to do whatever he wants in Britain? He
he wrote most of his works in a British
library in a in a um the British museum.
So why did the British authorities allow
him to do that? That's a question for
us, right? Britain is the most
capitalist country in the world at this
time, 19th century. And Britain
basically allow Marx to live there and
do whatever he wants. Okay, that's
strange. Number two is
Karl Marx. Where did he get his money
from? Okay, so Karl Marx actually his
wife is a German aristocrat. So she's
used to luxury. But Karl Marx never made
any money in his life, right? Who if he
writes these works, the Congress
manifesto, that's capital. No one's
going to read them. They don't sell,
right? So he's not a wealthy person, but
we know for a fact that he actually
lived a very good life. Okay? He wasn't
an aristocrat. He wasn't wealthy, but he
was middle class. His kids went to
private school. They had a nice house in
Britain.
So the question is, where did he get his
money from? Well, what they say is he
got his money from his partner Frederick
Engles. And where did Frederick Engles
get his money from? Well, his father was
a capitalist, an industrialist.
So there here's a question for you.
Why would his father who is a very
wealthy person
let give angles a lot of money to give
to Marx and Marx is calling for a world
revolution to destroy the capitalists.
Why would they do that?
Okay, that's kind of strange.
The third thing is that at this time
[snorts] socialism was the most dominant
ideology for many reasons. Okay. Okay.
And the idea of of socialism is that
um it will evolve naturally. Okay. But
Mark says no no no we cannot allow it to
evolve naturally. It will not evolve
naturally. We need a revolution.
Okay.
We need a world revolution.
Right? So that's a question for us. Why
would he say this? Okay. So, so let's
look at what socialism is and then let's
look at what communism is. Okay, let's
look at socialism. All right, the idea
of socialism is pretty simple. All
right, so before you had a feudal
society
and then it became industrial.
Because it becomes industrial, you have
lots and lots of workers,
okay? And you have capitalists.
[snorts and clears throat]
The problem though is that capitalism
exploits labor. It makes people very
unhappy. Okay? So the workers want
change. Then you have the industrialist,
the capitalist. The problem is that
capital
consolidates. Okay? So maybe you have a
thousand capitalists to start, but then
maybe 10 will take over all the money.
Okay? All the means of production, the
factories. Then maybe one, okay? Because
that's how capitalism works. It
consolidates which means that eventually
the capitalist will turn against
capitalism as well. Okay? And because of
democracy
because
people can vote, they can then together
affect political change and this will
lead to socialism.
What is socialism? Socialism is just a
redistribution of wealth.
Okay, a redistribution of wealth. Now
let's for for the sake of simplicity say
there are three classes. Okay, you have
the rich, you have the middle class
and you have the poor.
Okay?
Right? So all
redistribution is doing is taking the
money from the rich and giving it to the
poor. You understand? But because of
this, what happens is the middle class
improves in status and power.
Okay? So if you look at the system, you
would think, okay, look, the poor want
this system because they have more
money, they have more equality, but also
the people who really want the system
are the middle class because it means
that over time they have more power and
status than the rich, right? And this is
a pretty powerful coalition. That's why
socialists believe that over time this
is just a natural evolution. And this is
true for most of human history. Right?
So after World War II, Europe didn't
become communist. It didn't become
capitalist. It became socialist. It had
a very strong welfare system. Okay?
[snorts] So just the natural course of
human history, socialism will become
inevitable. Okay? Doesn't make sense to
you guys. Okay? Because this is a
majority of people.
But Mark's had problems with this. Okay,
Mark says, "Okay, all right. The major
problem with this is class, sorry, false
consciousness.
[snorts]
Okay, you think that this is a natural
process, but capitalists, the ruling
elite, have a lot of tricks up their
sleeves." Okay, for example,
um they can brainwash the workers,
right? So for this to work out, you need
to create true consciousness. So you you
need to destroy religion. You need to
revamp the educated system. You need to
control the media. Okay? Otherwise, the
capitalist will use the schools, the
media, religion to brainwash the
workers. And also these workers need to
unite together across the world to have
true power. Okay? Why? Because the real
struggle
is one of class. Okay? Consciousness.
And for socialism to arise, we need to
destroy class. Okay? So the idea of the
middle class
obtaining power, that's bad. What we
should have is just everyone the same.
Okay. Equality.
Right.
And that's the idea of Marxism to
destroy all property. Okay. That's the
that's the main difference between
socialism and communism. Socialism is
the redistribution of property.
Communism is the destruction of
property. But if you do it this way,
what happens is that the middle class
now lose [clears throat] status,
right? And so it's both the rich and
middle class that suffer under communism
and therefore they will probably unite
together against the poor.
You understand? So it sounds similar
socialism and communism, but it's night
and day.
Socialism seems like the natural
evolution of things.
Okay.
And so it sounds right. So why is Mark
screwing screw screw around this? Okay.
He also says that okay.
You also need a party.
You also need a vanguard, an elite
to destroy the false consciousness,
unite the workers and create a communist
society. And when they do that, when
when system is completely communist,
then the party will give up power and
you will have a socialist paradise.
But then the question then is
why would the party give up power?
Right? So if the part is capable of of
creating consciousness, why don't they
just switch to a different false
consciousness?
Okay. So the problem with Marx is that
it's working on socialism and making it
more extreme. It's also making it more
confusing.
And why would he do that?
Okay, it's very confusing now.
All right. And my argument to you is
that when this happens, when an idea
becomes more extreme,
the intention is to discredit it, to
make it illegitimate, to destroy the
idea. All right? So if you think about
it, according to game theory, the people
responsible for communism is not Marx.
The people responsible for communism are
the capitalists, the ruling elite
because they want to destroy the idea of
socialism, right? They don't want this
unity between the middle class and the
work and the workers. They want the
middle class to to remain with the
nobility and the oligarchy. Okay? Does
that make sense? All right. So, let me
show how this works. All right? So in
the field economy you have the monarch
and the nobility. Okay.
And the monarch nobility have power
through three mechanisms. First of all
they control the land.
Uh they control the military
and they control the religion. Okay. So
this is the status quo. And then the
peasants are the people who work the
land. And this was true for most of
Catholic Europe. But then with the rise
of industrialism, you have new people
come into power. Okay? So for example,
you have the boujo.
Who are the boujo z? Boura Z are just
the capitalists, the factory owners.
Okay? And because of the boujo, you now
have the workers.
And then because of this industrial
economy, you have the middle class.
Okay, the middle class are just like
lawyers, teachers,
accountants,
journalists, people who support the
industrial economy. All right? Now,
when this happens, when you have a uh
new groups of people emerge, you now
have tension, you have violence. Okay?
And this is ultimately what led to the
French Revolution
[snorts]
where the new order. Okay, these people
worked together to try to overthrow the
old order
and this led to the Napoleonic wars.
Seven wars fought between France and
everyone else. Okay. And that led to the
deaths of millions, tens of millions of
people in Europe. It was a deadly war.
And after Napoleon was defeated,
all the leaders, the the nobility of
Europe got together and sec and decided
that from now on we will no longer fight
war. Okay? They create something called
the concert of Europe.
The concert of Europe is basically
um these different monarchies agreeing
to resolve the differences
over negotiations rather than on the
battlefield. So think think of it as a
as a United Nations. Okay? and it worked
really really well. The problem is that
it worked too well because you're not
resolving this problem. Okay? You're not
resolving this conflict between the new
order and the old order,
right?
The these people want to maintain the
status quo,
but these people the industrial economy
wants a new a new um order that allows
for democracy.
Okay. Liberalism.
Okay. Socialism.
Okay. So, a more redistribution of
wealth. um greater participation in the
political system and the limitations of
the
uh religion. Okay. So basically the
French revolution.
All right.
So right now so this system was created
to avoid the French revolution but
because of peace
the ingredients for the re French
revolution are increasing. Okay. And
this led to something called the 1848
revolutions.
18848 revolutions.
And this happened throughout the
entirety of Europe where each place
there was a uprising a combination of
these people the borders middle class
and workers who called for changes in
government. Okay. Some places were
violent, some places were peaceful. Some
places focused more on democracy. Some
place focus more on liberalism. Some
places focus more on socialism. Okay.
All right. So, does that make sense?
After 1848, what the leaders of Europe
recognized is that you know what? If you
don't do anything about this situation,
eventually the new order is going to
consume us. The new order of the bouro
middle class and workers. This alliance
is going to destroy us. So, what can we
do about it?
Their solution is we have to divide
them. Okay, we have to divide them.
So before the conflicts were about
power,
status, religion. Okay. So the first
idea is let's create the idea that the
real conflict is class. Okay. So the
real enemy is not between the nobility
and the boujo.
Okay. The real enemy is between the
boujo and the workers.
Okay. This is the real conflict.
Right. Second is that
[snorts] we have to discredit
um these people and make this movement
seem extreme, fanatical, zealous. Okay?
And you do that by saying, "Okay, no
property." What we want is not a warfare
society. What we want is a completely
equal society where no one has any
money. No one has any rights. No one has
any freedom. Communism. Okay.
And the third way you deliberize it is
say that this is a international
conspiracy.
Hey guys, Jews.
These communists are in secret society
who want to take over the entire world.
So it's not that oh these workers just
want more rights. No, no, no. These
workers are tools in an actual
conspiracy to conquer the entire world.
They are funded by Jews, by capitalists,
by the British. Who cares? Okay? But
they're not Germans. They're not French.
They're not us. Do you understand?
So you think about it.
Communism was a scop,
okay?
A tool used by the elite, by the
nobility
to
make the movement of democracy,
socialism, and liberalism illegitimate.
Okay, this is his propaganda.
Okay, doesn't make sense, guys? All
right, so let's look at the evidence for
this.
All right. So this is the 1848
revolutions. So what happened was that
because of peace you have
overpopulation, you have economic
growth. Okay. That led to inequality
that led to corruption. That led to
conflict between the bourgeo the new
rising powers and the nobility the
status quo powers. Okay? And that's why
you have these revolutions throughout
Europe. Okay? So look at France. Okay?
This is a French um you look at like all
these places this happening all at the
same time
okay everywhere and again um different
systems will respond differently the
only place in Europe that's basically
speared these revolutions is England and
the reason why is that England has
colonies where if you're not happy you
can go somewhere else like Canada or
United States or Australia New Zealand
okay but you can leave but everyone else
is stuck where they are and they are
[clears throat] fighting for more rights
and again this puts the fear of God
into the European nobility. Okay, for
the longest time they got along they
maintain peace but now the boujo the
industrialists the capitalists want to
overthrow the regime. Okay. So what they
do now is they sponsor the creation of
communism to divide the capitalist the
middle class and the workers against
each other. Okay. Okay. To create the
idea of cast class conflict.
All right.
Um, okay. So,
Karl Marx and Feder Engles. All right.
They write something called the
communist manifesto. And this comes
after the 1848 revolutions because they
because after the 1848 revolution they
are absolutely convinced that Europe is
in is ready for a global revolution.
Okay. And this is their agenda and this
is also a secret document because at
this time the communists are secret
society all around Europe. Okay. And I
would argue that this was probably being
funded by the nobility. Okay. Okay. So
it calls for all abolition of property.
All right. No more property. That's
pretty extreme.
So be because again remember the middle
class wants to support socialism but it
cannot support communism. Socialism is
just a redistribution of wealth.
Communism is the abolition of wealth.
Two different things. All right. Um
all abolition of inheritance.
Okay. Again you're middle class. You're
like I worked really hard to make this
money. I want to give to my children.
Now I can't anymore. Okay. This is
pretty awful. All right. Centralization
of credit in the hands of the state.
Okay.
By means of a national bank. Okay. And
you think, okay, this is this sounds
pretty extreme, but you know what? We
they already do this in capitalism. It's
called the Bank of England, right?
All right.
So there are already some a lot of
similar between capitalism, communism.
Remember the Bank of England is where
all wealth from around the world is
stored, right? So a centralized bank and
communist system, it's the same thing,
right? Um centralization of a means of
communication, right? A party.
Well, this is just the capitalist class,
an oligarchy,
like does it really matter?
If um it's an oligarchy or a part, it's
the same thing really, right? um
extension of factories, instruments of
production owned by the state. Equal
liability of all work, combination of
agriculture, manufacturing industries.
All right? So this is the idea of
creating a politariat.
All right? Or manufacturing. And this
capitalist want guys. Okay? So for at
this time most of the world is a
agricultural feudal and this calls for
the creation of a manufacturing
industrial economy. That's what Cathols
want, right? Because that way they can
better exploit people.
Um, free education for all children. And
you're like, "Oh, well that's great,
man. Free schooling." No, it's not
because now you can brainwash them,
right? This is brainwashing.
So, you know, you're like, "Okay, well,
this agenda is communist. Well, if I'm a
capitalist, I'm okay with this agenda.
Right. I'm happy with this agenda.
What's wrong with this agenda?
Right.
All right. [snorts]
When the course development classations
have disappeared and all production has
been country enhanced vast association
of the whole nation, the public power
will lose its political character.
Political power socalled is merely
organized power of one class for
oppressing another. The politic during
its contest with the boujo is compelled
by the force of circumstances to arise
of its class. If by means of revolution
it makes itself the ruling class as it
sweeps away by force the old conditions
of production than it will along these
conditions have swept away the
conditions for the existence of the
class and antagonism of classes
generally and will thereby have
abolished its own supremacy as a class.
Okay. All right. So this sounds very
public but it's not. Okay. First of all,
it establishes the politarian and the
party are the real enemies, not between
the capitalist and the monarchy uh
between capitalism and religion. The
real conflict is class between the bar
and the and the um proletariat. Okay?
And for the politician to win, they need
a party. Okay? They need a vanguard
party. But hey, once this Vanguard party
establishes itself and destroys class,
it will go away. Okay, you understand?
It will give up power voluntarily.
It will choose to not exist anymore.
This has never happened in issue before,
but trust us on this one. Okay. This
time it will be different.
All right.
Okay. So, this is interesting. In the
communist manifesto it says okay
Switzerland we support the radicals in
Poland we support uh the aan revolution
in Germany we support the boujo sorry uh
um yeah the politarian okay so in
different places they have different
concerns they have different needs
right and what these people are saying
is that we're not part of the natural
conspiracy all we want is a more fair
just society that's all we Not we're not
part of a secret society bent on world
domination. What the communist manifesto
says is yes you are. Yeah, we're all
part of this great conspiracy to conquer
the world and establish communism.
Right. So why would they do that?
Why would they do that? That's really
strange guys, right? Why would they
admit we are a national conspiracy?
worst society. This is a secret document
that we read amongst ourselves. But it's
also possible for you to steal and show
that yes, there is this secret society
and that's a conspiracy of Jews who are
trying to destroy the world. Okay.
Really interesting.
Okay. So now I want to talk about 1917.
>> [snorts]
>> What happens in 1917 is this
World War I is breaking out, okay?
And
the Russians are losing the war. The SAR
uh Nicholas, he abdicates and now you
have a democratic government in Russia.
But then the Bullshiks,
the Bolsheviks are an extreme
communist faction. Okay.
They launched October revolution. So
basically they seize power for
themselves
and then have election. As you can see
from this election the bullshiks even
though they have seized power they're
not as popular
okay as the socialists. Okay the
socialists are going to argue for more
gradual change. The bullshiks want
radical change. So you can see 17
million people voted for the socialists.
Only 10 million people voted for the
Bovix even though the BICs controlled
the government. Okay? And also look look
at this. At the end of the day,
[clears throat]
they only got 23%
of the popular vote. Okay? So they are
not a popular
faction. They're a minority.
Okay? But and so this launches the civil
war. Okay. And as you can see at this
time in history, yes, the communists
have control over the major cities of
Russia, but they don't really control
most of Russia. In fact, they have lots
and lots of enemies. They have the
whites to deal with. The whites is
basically the nobility.
Okay? And they have also um allied
armies
who come in. They have the Greens who
are the peasants. Okay, they have lots
and lots of enemies. And at this time in
history, you could not possibly expect
that the Bviks would win this battle.
Okay, but they do.
All right, here's something interesting.
This is the Romanoffs. Okay, the
Romanoffs.
Sorry.
The Romanovs.
The Romanovs have been in power in
Russia for hundred years. Okay? And the
Romanovs are beloved by the peasants
and they themselves are part of the
Orthodox tradition.
They're also relatives of the nobility
of
um of Europe. Okay. So, England and
Germany.
All right. So, this is um the Sar
Nicholas II. The SAR here is Nicholas
II. Okay. Um and
and these are all his relatives. This is
the Romanov dynasty. [snorts] Now, when
the revolution broke out, you would
think that they would just run away to
Europe, right? Where their relatives
are. They didn't do that. They just
stuck around. So the question then is
why would they just stick around? The
answer is they never believe they were
in danger. Okay, first of all, they
could not expect the Bleviks to um win
out, but also they're beloved by the
peasants. Um they're part of the
Orthodox church tradition and they have
relatives who are the most powerful
people in Europe, including uh in
England, including in Germany, right?
The Kaiser. So they thought they were
fine. But then something strange
happens. The Blevix decides to kill
every one of them.
Okay? They wipe out the Romanov
family between 17 and 18
of members of the Romanov family were
assassinated.
And you're like that makes no sense. Why
would they do that? By doing that, first
of all, you piss off the peasants,
right? You turn the peasants peasants
against you because the peasants love
the the royal family.
You now get the families of Europe
pissed off at you because you kill their
relative, but also you come across as
fanatical bon revolution. Okay? And then
you piss off the orthodox as well. So
these communists are fanatics.
So, but let's assume they're not
fanatics and let's assume that in fact
they had a good reason to do this.
Why would they do that? Okay.
And the answer is this. The Romanovs had
billions and billions of dollars in
foreign banks.
Okay. in the city of London on Wall
Street. Okay. A lot of their wealth,
billions and billions of dollars is
stored overseas.
What happens if they die? What What
happens if they all die?
Right? Guess what? These billions now
belong to the foreign banks. That's a
lot of money, man. And in fact, this is
exactly what happened where
um they all died and the foreign banks
just took control over this money. And
this is one of the great controversies
of the 20th century. Okay? The
government of Russia has been trying for
a long time to get this money back. And
the far bank's like, "Well, you don't
own this money. It's a Romanovs who own
this money."
Okay.
So, this is evidence that the communists
and the capitalists actually are
friends. They're working together.
Okay. Does that make sense, guys?
All right. [clears throat]
Let's continue.
All right. Another thing is that again,
the BVIS are not that popular.
Okay. The peasants are pissed off at
them because they just killed a noble
family. There aren't that many workers.
So, how can they fight this war? Well,
they fight this war using mercenaries,
okay, from Lavia, from China, from the
Hungarians. Okay, so there's over
200,000
of these mercenaries. And you're like,
wait a minute here.
How did these guys get paid? The
bushings don't have any money. How are
they getting paid?
Right? And the answer is, well,
Wall Street, guys,
Wall Street and the city of London gave
the bushfix money to pay these
mercenaries. It was Wall Street who paid
for these mercenaries. You like, why
would they do that? And the answer is
because the bullshiks to pay washi backs
created the red terror.
Okay. The red terror is when the
bolshvix basically went to all the rich
people in Russia. The nobility says you
either give me all your money or I will
rip your daughter. I will kill your
wife. I will kill you. Right? And guess
what? By doing that they made a lot lot
of money. And that and that money went
to pay Wall Street for the foreign
mercenaries. Again, capitalist and
communist work well together. Okay.
Then you have [clears throat]
the allies, right? So, Britain, America,
France, Japan sent these huge armies to
Russia. And everyone thought, okay, it
should destroy communism because these
are capitalists. They're afraid of the
communists. But in fact, that's how it
happened. Okay, they went to collect
debt.
Okay. So, Russia owed these countries
money. The Soviet the the Bolshevik paid
off his debt. So then the Allies left
and attacked the whites. Okay.
All right. So the Allies helped the
Bviks and Wall Street gave money to the
Bviks for mercenaries and that's how the
BVIS won the war. Does that make sense?
All right. So capitalist and communist
work well together because they have a
similar worldview.
All right.
So this is um a passage from a book
called Wall Street and the Russian
Revolution by Richard Spence. Okay. And
Richard Spence uh is a historian and he
had lots of documentation where Wall
Street is actually financing the BFIX
and he explains why this has happened.
He says that Wall Street
wants to destroy the Russian economy.
Okay, destroy the Russian economy
because Russia is a threat. Okay, and
then it wants to steal the riches and
the resources
from the Russians.
Okay, that's the purpose of financing
the bolshviks to destroy the Russian
economy and to steal the wealth of
Russia. All right, from 1918 until 1921,
the Bolshviks reduced Russia to an
economy based on barter and robbery.
Okay, so the basically stole everything
from the rich, the middle class, and the
poor to finance their war. [snorts]
Besides the opposition of private trade
and the destruction of the monetary
system, the red regime embarked on a
massive looting campaign, ransacking
palaces, bank vaults, churches and
museums. Okay, we call this asset
stripping. So basically
the bush destroyed their own society in
order to get the money to finance this
war in order to pay off Wall Street.
Okay. They they appropriated every
valuable they could get their hands on
and stash it all in a new state
treasury. By the close of 1921, an
estimated $450 million in valuables have
been sequester there with more to come.
Much of it that's going to be fenced
abroad for a fraction of its value in
capitalist hard currency. Okay. So
basically the Bviks stole everything in
order in order to finance the war. Okay.
And in the process by destroying their
tradition, by destroying their wealth,
by destroying their religion, by
destroying their nobility, it made the
Soviet Union now much more amendable to
capitalism. That's what happened when
Soviet Union fell. It became capitalist.
Okay. So that shows us it shows us is
that capitalism, communism are not
enemies. They're partners in world
conquest. And that's what the 20th
century is about. All right, any
questions?
So I think for for China when the China
is um officially recognized as a country
most of them said that we need to pursue
communism and abandon capitalism. But
there is like they followed Mark's
thinkings and like currently there's a
special term which is I think I don't
know the English name but it's called
Chinese unique socialism. I don't know
like is that a a way that the leaders
deal with when the country is you know
actually pursuing capitalist or is
actually pursuing capitalist but the
communism goal is just professed.
Okay. So [clears throat] China is an
interesting example because when Markx
was examining the world the two places
he didn't really consider are Russia and
China. Okay. Uh so marks
okay Russia and China
okay why the answer is because both are
a agricultural agarian or what he calls
feudal
so from his perspective Russia and China
have not reach a state of development
which is ripe for world revolution okay
for him the focus is on Germany
And this makes sense because remember
Britain Marx is being being supported by
Britain, right? And Britain is a great
enemy of Germany. So that's why Britain
would support Marx because he wants he
wants because Marx Marx is trying to
create a revolution in Germany which is
a great enemy of Britain. Okay, that
makes sense. So for Marx, he doesn't he
thinks that China and Russia don't
really matter because they're backward.
They're agricultural. They have
monarchies. Okay. So, so it doesn't
really fit into his model. But then
Lenin,
okay, came and said, "No, you can speed
up the revolution. Okay, you don't even
though peasants
peasants become workers if you have a
party to
help the process."
Okay. So, that was Lena's contribution.
And Mali is like, "No, you don't even
need workers, okay? You can have a
movement entirely on peasants." And then
once you have won the revolution, then
um you can create industrial revolution.
So really, if you think about it,
Mao wasn't really leading a communist
revolution. It was it was um you know,
it g it had the facade of communism, but
it was really a peasant uprising.
[clears throat]
Okay. So, Ma was not a great um
communist theoretician like Marx or
Lenin. Ma was a military commander.
Okay. So, he he he was no different from
other
um peasant leaders in the past. Um
people like um [cough and clears throat]
Janjang, okay, of of of the Ming
dynasty, these people.
Um but in order to create legitimacy
um in order to have support from the
Soviet Union from Russia they had the
communist facade.
Okay. And also communism provided a
framework in order to industrialize very
quickly. So what's important to
understand is that at this time in
history Mao was trying to actually work
with the United States as well. Okay.
Okay, he's trying to work with both the
Soviet Union and the United States. The
United States wanted to support Changesh
Chai. So when Mao won basically uh the
United States shut off China, embargo
China which forced uh Mao to fully
embrace communism. Okay.
Right. But for Mao, communism was not
that important. What's important is to
industrialize very quickly.
Industrialization.
Okay. So for him what's important is
industrialization. The other idea is the
idea of national sovereignty.
All right? So he didn't really want to
be controlled by the Soviet Union. If
China was fully communist then Soviet
Union would say well you're our you're
our little brother. Okay. But for M what
was important is national sovereignty.
And that's what ultimately led to the
Sino Soviet split in 1957. Okay. Does
that make sense?
>> All right.
Okay.
So can we understand that
capitalist equals to communis communism
or uh capitalism equals to communism or
communism is a weapon of capitalism but
like if we try to pursue communism at
the end we will finally achieve
capitalism.
Okay.
All right. [clears throat]
So capitalism
is the belief that you can shut society
around capital.
Okay.
And this is a direct threat to the old
order. Okay. The old order
which focus on uh religion [music]
um the king
the military.
Okay. So the capital is like no let's
get away with all this complexity.
Let's just make capital the basis of of
society. Okay. Now what happened is that
as these two systems came into conflict.
All right. Um the workers wanted
socialism. Okay. Social democracy.
So
capitalism
um from capitalism you had social
democracy right? Social democracy is is
is easy. Okay. Yes. Yes we believe in
capitalism but we believe in restraints
on capitalism. We believe on a fair
distribution of capital. All right. And
that makes sense because well um you
can't just have a few people with all
the money. Okay. All right. But what
happened was social democracy was both a
threat to the old order as a threat to
communism as well. Right? So the old
order capitalism what they did was they
would mutate social democracy into
communism
in order to delegitimize okay
delegitimize
social democracy to make it this into a
threat against everyone. Okay? Does that
make sense? Right. So to summarize,
capitalism is just a natural outgrowth
of history. But this comes in conflict
with the old order and capitalism will
give birth to social democracy. All
right? Which which is a natural response
to capitalism. Social democracy become a
threat to both the old order as and as
well as capitalism. Capitalism and the
old order are also in conflict with with
each other. So what they do is they
conspire to create communism. Okay.
Okay. So in the early days communism is
being supported by both the nobility and
the and the capitalists but for
different reasons.
All right. And then what happens is that
because of this support communism
becomes much more extreme which leads to
bullsheism.
Okay.
Or um revolution.
[clears throat]
Right. Right. Does that make sense how
the system worked out? So, so we can't
say, okay, well, they all had this plan
out. No, it's actually much more
organic, much more confusing than that.
At first, they had communism just as a
scop. Okay, no one actually believe
that. Oh my god, from communism, you'll
have bullshism. Okay, because bchism is
just crazy. Okay. But at first they
thought communism was crazy but then it
became much more mainstream and that led
to the birth of bullshism which became
which was really crazy at that time but
over time it also became more extreme uh
sorry became much more mainstream which
led to the rise of communism everywhere
including [clears throat] in China.
Okay.
So 1917
[snorts]
the October revolution
it was a wild gamble and it worked
because of the greed of capitalists.
Okay. But once it worked out once
communism was established in Soviet
Union then it changed the way people saw
the world and they thought that now
communism is possible anywhere including
in China.
Okay. Does that make sense?
All right. Any more questions, guys?
Okay. Great. All right. So, we go on
break for a month and then we come back
from the break. What we're going to do
is we're going to learn, we're going to
take all that we've learned, okay? All
this history, all this game theory and
apply it to the modern world. So, we
look at specific current events. So,
during the break, I want you guys to
focus on current events, reading news,
right? So, uh America is about to attack
Iran Iran soon. Um, America is going to
take over Greenland Canada. Um, Trump is
vis visiting China in April. There's
there's going to be a lot of news for us
to cover. Okay. So, uh, during the
break, uh, please focus on keeping up
with current events. All right. Okay,
guys. All right. See you after the
break.